each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
if we're going to three since then he's
doing for a very much great well it's
fun to see so many familiar faces i
titled my talk a low-level approach to
programming language infrastructure i
wanted to suggest to you that the the
language infrastructure i have in mind
is really what we want to support
research and i like you to be thinking
that your research in language is we
hope is driven by new ideas these find
their way into languages as features and
then there's a critical point where we
want to actually be able to build things
and play with them as so it you're
building things implying with them being
much more fun than discovering facts
about physics and in order to do that we
have to have implementations and what we
need from our implementations is
something that's good enough that
programmers will actually use the
features that embody the interesting
ideas that's sort of the the end goal of
language research and unfortunately this
often means that we have implementations
that require a lot of engineering and so
the the path that I'm pushing in my
research is try to find ways of building
infrastructure that's reusable so that
we can do that engineering once and then
take advantage of it for exploring lots
of different ideas now the word
infrastructure is yours pretty loosely
in the community but i think the modal
definition is really something like this
where you're you are thinking about
fairly old languages like Fortran RC
putting all of your emphasis on
optimization maybe a little bit of
emphasis on architectural exploration
and that's that's been the sort of
picture of compiler infrastructure for
at least 20 years and I'm happy here if
you want to sort of cross out C++ and
put in c-sharp a Java there but the
story is is primarily from the compiler
community primarily about optimizations
there are other language infrastructures
around a big one done here of course the
the Java Virtual Machine and these give
you a lot more stuff than just an
optimizer and if you use one of these
things you can expect that there's going
to be a particular language model you
think of you know Java or C sharp for
which this infrastructure works very
well but the reason that it works well
is that there's a lot of stuff built in
and along with the sort of nice reusable
stuff built in there are a lot of
assumptions so you're with these big
infrastructures it's rather difficult to
come in and tweak things and change the
assumptions so is either these are very
nice if the language model that the
infrastructure is using is the language
model that you want to explore not so
nice otherwise so what I'm talking about
infrastructure I really want to have
reuse in mind so the problem that my
students and I are trying to solve is to
let you pick the programming language of
your choice and the Machine of your
choice and we'll do our vet help you get
a quality implementation of that
language on that machine and today I'm
really going to talk just about the
language end of things and what we're
what we're trying to do to build an
infrastructure that can be reused with
many different languages in thinking
about this I what has come to the fore
for us as the other part of this title
which is what's the level of abstraction
at which you build your infrastructure
and how does a level of abstraction
affect your ability to reuse things
unless I want to sort of talk about this
pictorially and imagine that you up at
some high level abstraction I have C
sharp or Java or you know whatever the
the new thing is
and I'm not in this talk really going to
think at any lower level than assembly
code so I'm going to imagine that the
job of my implication is to get get down
to assembly code and how am I going to
going to do it and in my view things
like the common language infrastructure
the Java Virtual Machine live here adds
a level that's very close to the source
code and so there's a whole bunch of
important things in the language
implementation that are below that level
and so these are things which if you
happen to want to use your the garbage
collector the thread model the type
system that's provided by the
infrastructure you're in great shape
because there's a lot of a lot of
implementation effort behind it but if
these are the areas in which you want to
do your research and you want to
exchange change things you want to
explore alternatives then the big
infrastructures are not so good so we're
working on an infrastructure called C
minus minus where we're trying to
operate at this low level much closer to
the machine then to the source code and
the reason that this is you this is
interesting is that there's actually a
lot of hard stuff in here that is
expensive to build a lot of effort
invested and therefore were three using
yeah
next thing which has very little oh
right yeah Phoenix lives down in down in
here as well and Logan Phoenix has ever
seen wow compares I have not I have
looked in Phoenix and seeing that it is
big so so that that's yet a summer
student this past summer look at Phoenix
and didn't really get anywhere so you
know I talked with Dave a little bit i
would i would love to be able to make
those comparisons a little bit better
but i can't do it here so i want to talk
a little bit not just about what level
the abstractions are but kind of you
when they happen and an interesting
thing has that has changed since people
started trying to build reusable
compiler infrastructure is that more and
more stuff is happening at at at runtime
so you here are some kind of obvious
things that you art aren't part of for
tree on our see that you we want to be
thinking about for for future languages
and code generators like GCC or VPO
which were built with with a Fortran and
C model in mind our kind of caught
unprepared to deal with these kind of
features and it's not you know I don't
it's it's not sort of an accident or a
lack of foresight that makes it
difficult to for these infrastructures
to deal with with runtime services they
don't quite have the right model of what
the infrastructure should look like so
this is you more or less a replica of
the generic infrastructure picture that
I showed you
where we're starting with you know some
source code and you've got a front-end
back-end and in some kind of
intermediate form and so the question is
if this is what your world looks like
where are you going to put the things
that happen at runtime so I'm as an
example I'll pick the garbage collector
say where we going to put the garbage
collector well the garbage collect it
can't be just part of the front end
because in a garbage collector you have
to find roots roots are in variables and
only the backend knows you know what
machine registers those variables occupy
you might be able to put the garbage
collector in the back end if you get a
little bit of information from the front
end so for example that the front end
can somehow tell the back end as part of
the IR these are the variables that are
the roots so there are a number of
infrastructures that have have done this
where the a characterize this is saying
that the the fact that the garbage
collector is there is sort of implicit
in the IR it becomes an additional
property of this compile-time interface
between the the the front end and the
back end and the risk that you take
there is that when you make the thing
implicit it's a it's a little bit hard
to see what are the right semantics and
the cost trade-offs so an example in the
garbage collection arena is are you
going to allow objects to move when
they're when they're garbage collected
this is some interesting work by nick
benton and andrew kennedy on compiling
standard ml to the Java Virtual Machine
and they ran into trouble because the
JVMs of the day were designed you not to
allow objects to move to make for easy
interoperation with C code on the other
hand that slows down the allocator and
ml was designed to allocate like crazy
so Nick and Andrew rule had to but their
heads up against this you how are we
going to design an ml allocator that
tries really hard I start an ml compiler
that tries really hard not to allocate
keep objects so that's an example where
if you sort of build in the you're the
garbage collector in
you know sort of hide it behind this
interface you wind up with the wrong
cost trade-offs for some clients so
that's that's you know sort of the
message here that you every time you
build a sort of big piece of
infrastructure you're forced to make
certain decisions and those decisions
are going to be good for some clients
and not not for others so we're trying
to figure out how to be a little bit
more nimble than that and put together
an infrastructure that can be usable for
more clients so the goal here is to say
well you let's distinguish mechanism
from policy find the right set of
mechanisms so that different clients
different front ends can put things
together in different ways to get the
semantics and cost trade-offs they want
and you'll be sure that we can support
the standard implementations without
having to pick one and so that what
we're trying to accomplish is to allow
the front end to make the important
decisions about semantics and cost
trade-offs and really to pull this off
we need a new view of what
infrastructure means so this is really
the the one thing to remember about C
minus minus if you want to remember only
one thing and that it's an
infrastructure with with two interfaces
so on the left here we have the same
picture that I showed you before where
you've got your source code your
intermediate form and your generated
code and this is all the stuff that
happens at compile time but then down
here we have things that that are
happening at run at runtime so it's a
runtime system that goes with the front
end it might contain the garbage
collector and then an infrastructure
runtime that's there to support it so
the picture is very color-coded these
red boxes involve things that are
actually active in a running image so
you have a program you generate some
code and that runs with your runtime
system and our runtime system and all
three are cooperating to get to get some
jobs done these gray backgrounds are
intended to indicate loosely
speaking modules in the Dave parnis
sense that every module hides a secret
so here the front end and the front end
runtime system are in bed together and
they know all of each other's secrets so
for example they know all about the
layout of heap objects that information
is hidden from the back end here the
back end and the back end runtime system
they know all of each other secrets so
for example they know all about the use
of machine registers but that
information is is hidden from the front
end so to achieve this kind of
separation concerns or information
hiding we need not one interface but two
there's a compile-time interface that
looks very much like your typical low
level intermediate code and then also
the runtime interface which you can
think of as sort of exposing just enough
of the backend secrets that the
front-end runtime system can do its job
so because this is the new idea I wanted
to give you a quick scenario for a
problem that I hope will be familiar
it's the problem of allocating and
initializing a new object so a popular
implementation strategy to do this is to
try to inline some of the allocation and
initialization so you might generate
some C minus minus code to see if you've
got enough room for a new heat new
object if not called the garbage
collector once you know you're ok you're
going to advance an allocation pointer
reserved space for the object initialize
fields and do all of that in line so
that's being generated code for from the
front end then the garbage collector is
going to live in the front end runtime
system do the usual things of scanning
routes and reclaiming memory but in
order to scan routes the garbage
collector is going to build on the C
minus minus runtime interface and so
that's going to give it the ability for
example to grab a call stack look at
each activation and in each activation
find those local variables that have
been marked by the front end as routes
and so that's a sketch of how the
runtime interface generated code all fit
together to get things done
so what we are trying to accomplish is
to support multiple languages each with
its own front end garbage collector your
runtime system etc we're hoping that
this will be a little bit easier than
compiling to a higher level interface
like the JVM the clr or see you because
for example you don't have a high level
type system that might be the wrong
tight system and we believe that this
model can get you code that will be
almost as good as what you'd get with a
custom code generator and I want to
emphasize that although we've been
spending enormous amounts of effort on
implementing this system the real
intellectual problems here are problems
in interface design how do we we
separate concerns and introduce an
abstraction layer that lets us get good
code and also lets us get reuse so
that's a set of problems that we're
trying to solve and really the key idea
in the solution is that the
infrastructure should have two
interfaces the compile time and the
runtime what I'm going to do in this
talk I'm going to give you a very
sketchy overview of C minus minus both
the compile time and runtime interfaces
and then i'm going to show you two case
studies of so you can see you does this
story play out nicely is it possible to
provide low-level mechanisms that that
are reusable and then because there are
so many great people here who know a lot
about this stuff i want to tell you
about what i think is our most most
important open problem and with luck
while I'm here I'll get a chance to talk
with you about some of you about the
issues and ways we might tackle that
problem so I'm going to start with this
this overview c minus minus is a
language rather than api which
distinguishes it from many other
infrastructures there are a couple of
other reasons for this one is that the
community has better tools for
specifying what a language means and how
to use it correctly you we have let you
lots of things for formal semantics
we're not quite so good on that on the
proper use of AP is a language is also
easy to use
sort of purely software engineering
sense not necessarily in intellectual
sense but this allows you the freedom to
pick any tool chain you want for the
front end that you all tools can
generate ascii ascii programs and so
you're not tied to a particular
implementation language in which an API
might otherwise be expressed the picture
is not all rosy however and there
there's a price to be paid and the
primary price is that there are no up
calls you know when you've emitted a
program and handed it off to the C minus
minus compiler we can't sort of go back
and ask the front-end questions or ask
the front end for resources so there's
some places where the interface is more
complicated than we'd like it to be
because you're any information that we
might want to have really has to be
present right there in the program so
that's the the overall structure
something that I parently have worked
very hard on is to make sure that a C
minus minus program has a semantics
that's completely independent of the
target machine this is not the same as
saying that you're going to generate one
C minus minus program and run it
everywhere so one of the ways we we make
this meaningful is that a C minus minus
program has an explicit byte order and
explicit word size and you shouldn't
expect to run it efficiently on a
machine with divider or word size it's
got a very low level type system which
I'll sketch for you and the you can
think of the language as being
structured basically in two parts
they're the things that you would find
in an assembler to do with your data
imported and exported labels and then
the code is a bit more like what you
would find in a compilers intermediate
form so despite the name c minus minus
is not a subset of C I think the name is
really more marketing hype than anything
else
so here's the c minus minus program that
your runs on more backends that than any
other we have a number of incomplete
backends there's the explicit byte order
we have some imports and exports for
printf and main this is initialize data
labeled with H and then here I have a
main procedure called with the foreign
see calling convention takes arguments
argosy and RV it makes a foreign call to
printf and then returns so this is
everybody's everybody's favorite program
what are you seeing here well the names
and the types in this program are the
resolutely low-level so we have named
variables things like argh see and arg v
and these have the same semantics as
machine registers so for example there's
no such thing as taking the address of a
variable other names are first-class
immutable labels so you'll H labeling
this string or printf and main so these
these can't be mutated but they're used
as addresses in an address arithmetic to
get access to memory the type system is
at the Machine level we really have only
one important type that's a bit vector
type it is polymorphic in the width so
you can instantiate bit vectors at any
width and we compute bit vectors in the
language with expressions and you can
store them in these variables that have
register semantics and in the type
system there's no no hint of the meaning
of a bit vector so no distinction
between signed and unsigned or float and
integer instead as in the hardware or an
assembler these distinctions are in the
operator so we have both signed
comparisons and unsigned comparisons for
example we do have one other type it's a
boolean type and it's used only for
control flow so this is used in the the
if statement so there are no object
types know methods no method dispatch
you none of the high-level types that
you expect to find in a pro
gramming language because we want to
leave the client the freedom to pick
exactly what's the right type system how
should types be represented the there's
not a lot to say about the code it is
divided into expressions and statements
both of these get you know start with
either literal values or things that are
in registers or memory the expression
language is nearly pure with with the
one exception there there's really one
effect here which is going wrong so you
can mention / 0 as an expression with
the with the effect of going wrong and
that's an error from which you cannot
recover in C minus minus so if you want
to to let the hardware detect this from
you you have to to live in the statement
world the world of control flow so for
statements we have Dykstra style
multiple assignments and then we are
rich in control flow operations so we
have you know conditionals go to s are
computed with these first class labels
we have both call and explicit tail call
and then we have something i'll talk
about continuation and cut too which is
for control flow between distant distant
procedures one of the things that we're
trying to get at which we're very close
to is that if you have a particular
machine instruction in mind you know
what platform you're you're compiling
for it should be obvious to you what c
minus minus right to right to get that
machine instruction and so c minus minus
is expressive as long as we're willing
to distinguish computation and control
flow so lots of fancy things that we can
do but something like decrement and sore
and skip if zero is something that we
can't express because we divide
computation from control flow so that's
what the language looks like
the runtime interface i'm just going to
sketch i'll have you some details for
you later the idea behind the runtime
interface is pretty simple that we want
to be able to inspect and modify the
state of a suspended computation so if
you want to think of computations
executing on stacks we treat them as an
abstract data type so we can create new
stacks walk stacks in any activation we
can expect and modify variables the
front end can leave notes for its
runtime system in the source code key by
the program counter so we can can
recover those through the runtime
interface and then we have some ways of
unwinding the stack and transferring
control to two older activations for
their further down in the stack and I'll
show you some examples of these things I
want to talk you since i'm talking about
interface design i want to talk about
what is and is not hidden and that is
you you how where's the information
hiding how what are we going to try to
reuse so one thing that these interfaces
do hide is a number of facts about the
machines so for example the exact your
number and kinds of your machine
registers you don't need to know if the
hardware uses special registers for
integer multiply you exactly which
instructions you're going to pick to
achieve some computation that's hidden
more importantly what's hidden is you
know 20 years of pldi and another 20
years of optimization research before
that so you all of the sort of state of
the art register allocation instructions
scheduling peephole optimization and
pretty much everything that you read
about in the the dragon book in terms of
scalar and loop optimizations and we're
leaning very heavily here on the work of
Jack Davidson who has really spent 25
years showing that you optimizations
that at first blush appear to be a
fairly high level can actually be done
very effectively on very low level codes
so that's really the you know in some
sense you know what are we trying to
reuse in this infrastructure it's all of
this sort of optimization and machine
handling stuff that you read about and
it's really expensive to build now
there's some things that we're not
trying to hide in the interfaces and
really the the two critical ones are the
representation of the high-level types
you know how our high-level objects or
values represented on the target machine
and the control flow and the reason that
we're exposing these things is to enable
the front end to make decisions about
semantics and cost trade-offs and I'm
happy with this design and the design
decision primarily because these sort of
representation things are really pretty
easy to do in the front end you know
these are these are the things that you
want to be controlling you how are my
objects going to be laid out where am I
going to have in directions in method
tables all of those kinds of questions
and equally they are hard to reuse for
multiple languages because different
people want to decide these these
questions differently so that's what C
minus minus looks like in five minutes
or less and I now want to sort of
examine you can we put together
low-level mechanisms that that will
enable people to implement exceptions
and procedures in the ways that they
want to do so there's a fairly big
implementation space for exceptions one
space is is continuation passing style
where which exemplified by standard ml
of New Jersey popular one right now is
raising exception by cutting the stack
in constant time that's the way
objective camel works a long tradition
of unwinding the stack frame by frame in
the runtime system i've used polytechnic
module a 3 here because that's one that
i've had my fingers on so i know the
details and then there's been some other
systems like self which generated custom
code for on
the stack so C minus minus supports all
of these popular strategies some more
popular than than others in a single
framework and it does so by your
providing a set of low-level mechanisms
that essentially give you access to two
different cost models and so I want to
show you what are the cost models and
the mechanisms that support them so the
first model is raising exception in
constant time and we just want to view
this as a general control flow transfer
that transfers you not to a label but to
a program point within a particular
activation of some procedure and the
Machine level this is really simple it
says essentially you know I want to
change the stack pointer and the program
counter and bam I'm in a new place now
we don't expose the stack pointer in the
program counter but we bundle them up
together and provide this language
construct called cut 2 which has exactly
this implementation this is very quick
for things like exceptions or context
switching but as always there are
trade-offs the big trade-off is that
when you're doing this you cannot
restore values of Kali saves registers
and if you think about how do Kali say
as registers work well you're kind of
you're calling procedures going down the
stack and register might be saved at any
one of these activations sort of between
you where you're going and where the
exception is raised so it sort of by
definition you can't visit an arbitrary
number of activations in constant time
so you simply can't get these things
back this means that you not only are
these no good if you raise an exception
but they're less useful in the normal
case because if they're if they're live
on a path that goes through an exception
those values are live you can't put them
in Kali saves registers so one of the
things people do is your people who like
this model like the objective camel
people will just say all right I'm not
going to use any Kali says registers in
my compiler and so that mitigates this
another cost is that you know this
handler actually has to be a dynamic
value that contains a stack pointer and
program counter you're interested in and
that means that there's typically a
small
some few instructions to capture this
value when you enter the scope of a
handler so entering the scope of a
handler is not free so here's the other
cost model this is the the one frame at
a time model and the idea is that I'm
going to transfer control during an
exception dispatch by visiting
activations one at a time and visit each
frame so you can do that through the
change activation procedure in our
runtime interface and C minus minus
behind the scenes will restore the Kali
saves registers as you go so in a single
stack walk you can you restore the Kali
saves registers find the handler and get
to the point to which you wish to
transfer control what's the penalty for
all this the penalties that raising
exceptions expensive but this is what
some language designers want some
language designers have said it is okay
to spend 10,000 instructions in the
exceptional case in order to save one
instruction in the normal case and you
do have some savings in the normal case
notably you can enter the scope of the
handler a handler with what's called
zero overhead and what this means is
that you don't execute an instruction to
know that you've entered a handler but
rather you have a table index by the PC
that says if the PC values in this range
I'm in the scope of this handler there's
other trade-offs to be made so for
example if you want to generate more
code but have this goal faster you can
compile in some of the code to do the
stack on winding rather than do it
interpreted Lee in the runtime system so
those are the sort of the big choice of
cost model what are the mechanisms that
make all this possible well the first
mechanism I've already talked about
which is the the runtime interface so we
can capture the activation at the point
where the exceptions being raised walk
the stack get descriptor is a general
routine that allows you to find any kind
of front-end data that's indexed by the
program counter so this might be the
scope of handlers you can you reach in
and look
local variables and when you found your
handler you can you make a continuation
at that point and change the flow of
control to go to that place in that in
the handler so the the continuations
represent the next mechanism and this is
a mechanism that we use all over C minus
minus any time we want to talk about
control flow to something other than you
the same procedure or immediate caller
or colleague so a way to think about the
C minus minus continuation is that it's
a generalization of label that includes
the activation as well as the program
point it is a first-class value but it
is not at all like a scheme continuation
because it has a limited lifetime and so
it's going to be created on entry to
procedure and create continuations for
that activation and then they died when
the activation dies so here's an example
where I've got a procedure I've got some
main code which might transfer to
continuation k through stack unwinding
or stack cutting and then continuation k
is going to stand for this point in this
activation so the trade-off here is that
by giving this thing a limited lifetime
we make it dirt cheap and it caught
you're depending on how you want to use
it it may cost nothing or a couple of
instructions to capture a continuation
so the the support we provide for
control transfer with the continuations
we have the cut to which I mentioned in
the language and we also have put cut
two in the runtime interface so you can
can go directly either way and then the
unwinding model is a bit more elaborate
I've shown you the stack walk when you
reach the activation you want to be your
destination you actually you build a
continuation dynamically and this is
this is the thing that sits will restore
the Kali saves registers and transfer
control and then cut to that that
activation we also provide some language
support for stack unwinding through
something that has various names in
literature you might have heard a multi
return point might have heard of
vectored returns you might have heard
from alternate returns if you're
familiar with with the original clue
implementation of signals of a frame at
a time exceptions that's probably the
closest parallel in a high-level
languages but it simply says that a call
site can have multiple return points and
you can pick which one you want to go to
so the alternate return mechanism is
very fast and there's one privileged
case the normal return which doesn't
have any any dynamic overhead so how do
we know about these these multiple
return points well the third piece of
mechanism is an annotation language
that's used at the call sites so every
call site in every C minus minus program
may have multiple continuations and so
the annotations identify what
continuations are available in a call
site and they serve two purposes one is
just to tell the optimizer you know
what's going on where are the control
flow edges what's happening so that we
can optimize in the presence of these
kind of exceptional control flow without
breaking the program and then some
annotations will trigger the
construction of tables which are used by
the alternate return mechanism or by the
stack on winding
listen to support those things so here's
a completely artificial example showing
you every possible continuation from a
call site so here I'm passing X 2 G and
I have the normal return continuation
which carries us this value our this
annotation also cuts to k-12 us a
compiler that it should put a control
flow edge from this call site into the
program point at k1 and it should note
that flow along that edge does not
restore the collie sees registers so
they get killed and anything that's live
on k1 at k1 will therefore be guaranteed
not to be in a collie say's register at
this site the unwinds to produces a
similar pair of flow edges 12 k to 12 k
3 but these control flow edges preserve
the values of kali say's registers so
it's okay for the compiler to have
something live at k2 or k3 in a collie
saves register the also returns to as
far as the optimizer is concerned
behaves exactly like the unwinding to
but it does a little bit more work in
order to build a table for the
implementation of the alternate return
mechanism and then also aborts is a flow
edge that that tells the optimizer we
might abort this entire activation while
suspended at this call site so please
put in a flow edge from here to the exit
node now you will never write this in a
program because there's this I can't
imagine a situation where you want all
of these mechanisms instead you're going
to be deciding through what is the right
semantics the right cost trade-offs for
your angel procedural control flow and
you'll pick the annotations that go with
the trade-offs you've chosen
the last piece all I mentioned briefly i
mentioned get descriptor before for
looking up information like what handler
mind the scope of this is a general
construct that defines a key value pair
and can be wrapped around any
well-formed region of the of the program
and then what the get descriptor does is
present a key and it and the runtime
system knows your where computation is
suspended at what program point and it
finds the smallest enclosing span with
that key and returns the association
associated value so we use this for
marking the scope of handlers we use it
for marking routes for garbage
collection we use it for laying down
information for source level debugging
it's a general mechanism for the front
end and the fronton runtime system to
share their secrets without telling the
backend what they mean so this is how we
cover the implementation space of
exceptions that you're the new the big
cost trade-off is whether you're going
to walk the stack and when you've made
that decision we provide you with
appropriate mechanisms to do what you
want either in the generated code or in
the runtime system so this is an area
where I'm reasonably happy with the
story about providing low-level
mechanisms that that you let you choose
things you want to do what I want to do
next is look at the procedures in the
same light and if you've been following
closely you should be a little bit
grumpy about procedures because they
don't really have the properties that
I've been arguing for procedures are not
a machine level abstraction in the way
that bit vectors are and you have your
justice with the garbage collector the
problem that we can't really pick your
one semantics or set of cost trade-offs
that's going to work for all clients so
that the most obvious example is that
you can support standard C calling
conventions or you can support general
tail calls you can't do both in the jaw
case they're they're antithetical
moreover the procedures carry your costs
for parameter passing and saving and
restoring registers that are your
machine dependent and not obvious to the
to the consumer so you're the your
procedure is in general not a mechanism
that has the properties that we would
like to have and C minus minus so why
are we there well we're there because
sign Payton Jones and I worked very hard
for about a year to take them out and we
just weren't smart enough but I think
you we at least can come up with good
reasons why we we weren't smart enough
what do you have if you have an
infrastructure without procedures well
you clearly want to be able to compile
languages that have things like
procedures and methods and so now what
are you asking the front end to do well
it has to figure out how machine
registers are going to be shared among
different methods or objects that means
you have to invent conventions oh by the
way you have to deal with C procedures
you're going to want to manage stacks of
some Klein that that is you have to
worry about stack overflow and stack
underflow so suddenly now you're not
getting a whole lot of reuse here
because we're really requiring the the
front end to do a lot of work so this is
a design decision that I think is okay
in part because it is hard to do it's
it's a lot of work but also because
we've been able to come up with a
mechanism that works reasonably well as
a target for many different languages
that you your languages like your
prologue or ml or or ray is C sharp that
might have you quite different models of
you what it means to call something and
how you're going to decide where to
transfer control there are some useful
reusable concepts at the low level but
this still leaves us with the issue of
semantics and cost trade-offs so what
we've done here is rather than sort of
you have piece parts in the language for
the casual user we just say here
procedures here's a reasonable default
Colin can
vention and we'll give you access to the
foreign see calling convention and then
for the users who really want to control
semantics and and cost trade-offs we
give them hooks into the implementation
that are there specifically to do that
and so I want to talk to you a little
bit about how how we've structured that
but the your the lesson here for me is
that you if as a designer I want to put
a high level abstraction into my
infrastructure and I want people to
reuse it I have to work harder so the
implementation of procedures is messy
there's there's a lot of different your
details to think about you can use for
register conventions which way the stack
grows most of these things can be dealt
with pretty simply by writing down the
answers and the main issue is that there
are a lot of answers to write down the
two more interesting and difficult ones
i will talk a little bit about how
values are communicated between collars
and collies and about how we how we want
to control the layout of the stack frame
because those are both areas where we
have to do a bit more work so at a high
level the story about parameter passing
is really easy and that you know we'd
like to pass parameters and registers
yeah that's that's the that's the main
goal and we also have to deal with the
fact that there are only finitely many
registers and so in some cases we're
going to have to pass things on this on
the stack so all we need to do is figure
out you know which registers we're going
to pass things in and we'll be good to
go now the C minus minus type system by
itself doesn't provide any information
that would you allow you to decide for
example whether something should go in
an integer register or a floating point
register so in the in the call and
return languages each parameter and
result is annotated with a kind and to c
minus minus the kind is an uninterpreted
string
but you can think of this as capturing
just enough information about the
high-level type so that you can make a
good guess about what sort of register
you'd like to pass a thing in and so
you're three kinds that will suffice for
an awful lot of machines are you know
the empty kind which you can imagine a
general purpose register the address
kind you can think of a 68,000 pointer
register or the float kind you can think
of a floating point register so it's the
implementations job to advertise what
kinds are significant on what machines
and then the high-level client has to
has to decide how things are going to go
into work and it is pretty easy to take
types in something something like see
and say well there's going to be a
32-bit value that's part of the C minus
minus type system and I'm going to pass
with this with the empty kind or the
care star 32 bits with a dress kind
floating values are going to have float
kinds so this is that you're the you
know the big step that's going to be
potentially different for different
targets and have to be redone once we've
got that we've reduced this to an
allocation problem and we have a very
simple yo sequential allocator where we
take the parameters or results one at a
time present the width and kind get back
a location and get ready to allocate a
location for the the next parameter
what's interesting that we've done is to
put together a little language for
composing allocators that gives us the
ability to do a lot of different
strategies as well as support the
standard calling conventions so I'm not
going to show you the language but
rather just a couple of examples so
here's the parameter passing convention
for see on the Pentium everything gets
widened to a multiple of 32 bits and
then they all go onto the stack and in
fact a particular area on the stack the
overflow block which can grow
arbitrarily large to hold arbitrarily 90
/
nurse so this is something that our
compiler reads at startup so that it
knows what the foreign see calling
convention means if you want a different
calling convention you just provide it
different code at startup time you don't
have to rebuild the compiler here's the
c return convention which is a little
more interesting there's a choice stage
here that for results of floating-point
kind are 80 bits wide and get returned
on the top of the floating-point stack
and any other result is widened to a
multiple of 32 bits and as either
returned in register eax or EDX and
there's no overflow block here so if you
try to you return multiple results or
you run out of registers the compilation
will fail and say that you've gone past
the calling convention the sea calling
convention does not support the return
of multiple results what a dot sorry a
dot is the is the is a is the module
that holds all of the the combinators
for the the staged allocation so so this
is just a yes the little language for
specifying conventions is built into the
compiler and then then by my own
well so that the a module is the if you
see what's in the a module it's things
like your widen you use registers this
is the always true predicate choice
there's no it's just a Combinator
language there's no actual you're the
calling convention content lies in how
the parameters are used so what this is
doing is registering the the see Colin
convention with the x86 back end does
that answer that means I can just think
of a dot choice I am I the city keywords
and yes you can absolutely think that
just think of them as keywords yeah why
that's beeping all right speaking
because my class starts in five minutes
luckily someone else is teaching it so
here's a picture of a more complicated
calling convention this is the the Alpha
C calling convention which uses both the
floating-point and integer registers but
when it dropped something in one of
these registers then sort of labels the
other one saying I don't use this so we
specify that a convention by counting
how many bits of parameters have been
allocated and then when we get a
parameter we make a choice based on its
kind again your floating or not floating
and then the floating point parameter is
allocated into a floating point register
in a position determined by this counter
an integer parameter is allocated an
integer register in a position
determined by this counter and then when
we run out of registers both of these
things wind up on the stack in the
overflow block so give you a little
flavor of how this this works we have
specified standard C calling conventions
for nine different machines and they're
you know they're mostly pretty small
that the pentium and alpha examples are
perhaps slightly more complicated than
than average you the simplest things or
things like the backs most complicated
is the MIPS which has some very unusual
inventions for the use of registers the
implementation is very simple that this
we have this little language that has
these sort of simple allocators like
sequence of registers as base cases some
Combinator's we've given it a precise
semantics and the implementation in ml
is is very small and then the student
who worked with me on this took the same
semantics and implemented it in C++ to
try it out in a different compiler the
machine sweet compiler and it's a bit
bigger here but still quite manageable
if you want to put this in into a
compiler the other thing that I'm just
going to sketch is the stack frame
layout you'll often see in calling
specifications these kinds of pictures
and we have a little declarative
language which essentially allows us to
name each of the blocks or pointers in a
picture like this and say this is the
way that that the blocks should be laid
out what we're achieving by this is just
to decouple the stack frame layout from
the phase ordering in the compiler so
each of these you know little regions
has a symbolic address we allocate in
those regions and then when we're all
done allocating we lay out the stack the
stack frame you either you know we have
things that that are live at the same
time that that are concatenated or for
example if we have things associated
with different call sites that aren't
live at the same time we can overlap
them we wind up with a bunch of
constraints we have a very simple linear
equation solver essentially stolen from
knuth solver for meta font and know all
these symbolic addresses just become in
directions from the stack pointer so
that's you another problem that we've
been able to solve perhaps not as nicely
as expression and as I said at the
beginning I want to tell you about what
I think is the most important problem we
have left and that is
what do we need to do to support
concurrent languages in a reusable
infrastructure so there are a lot of
interesting problems here probably more
than then we can handle by ourselves the
things that we're most aware of as being
important are what's the memory model
how do we want to deal with
synchronization or do we want to have
some form of your transactions or lock
free interactions between threads but
the one that I've highlighted is the
management of the stack for a concurrent
language and you did this as you
probably have guessed you're the C minus
minus runtime interface is very very
heavy on dealing with dealing with the
stack and the implementation of the
stack affects the things that you can do
so the your the reality that we live
with is that you're the operating system
will give a sort of at most one
apparently infinite stack if we want to
have more than one threads it's up to
the language to manage finite stacks so
you need to know how many threads you're
going to have if you're going to have
just a handful you can allocate big
stacks if you want a lot your stacks had
better be small are you going to detect
stack overflow I'm always amazed that
this is a question that there are you
you know people located in certain areas
of New Jersey who just want to allocate
big stacks and hope that they don't
overflow are you willing to move a whole
stack or a stack frame do you require
that the stack be contiguous are you
willing to split it into pieces what if
you want to go beyond just your threads
you want to think about scheme
continuations and you're copying stacks
you want to copy stacks lazily so there
are a host of different ways to answer
these questions and I attempted to get
answers from A to Z and so I have at
least a left to shake scheme there
we're focusing on the stack because
you're in C minus minus there's a lot of
stuff we can we expose but the Stars
it's an abstract data type and so it's
up to us to do it right what we have at
present is completely unsafe and that
will just you allow you to create a
stack and run on it and hope that it
that doesn't overflow so I've been
working with a student the student the
spring on the detection of stack
overflow and the ideas that you when we
create a stack will have some opaque
value that the backend knows to look at
to find out if the stack is exhausted
we'll put a limit check into the run
into the compile time interface the C
minus minus language and then start to
think about the movement and other
things at runtime and I'll say a bit a
bit more about this so the limit check
is like some of the garbage collection
things and that not the knowledge you
need is divided among the front end in
the back end so only the front end knows
where to find the stack limit which is
for example it's a policy decision
whether you want to burn a register to
hold the stack limit limit cookie only
the front end knows what to do if you
run out of stack on the other hand only
the back end knows how big any
particular frame is only the back end
knows you how much Headroom do you need
to save state and recover if you run out
of stack so there there has to be
something in the interface to enable
this kind of cooperation the way we're
doing the limit check is that we allow
the front end to put limit checks
anywhere in the the procedure that they
like and the limit check cuts the flow
graph into confined and unconfined
regions so front end to put any code it
likes in either region but the confined
region is going to be confined to a
bounded amount of stack space saw amount
of headroom that's chosen at compile
time and is shared across compilation
units whereas the unconfined region can
use arbitrary as much stack space as it
likes because the limit check will have
guaranteed that that stack is available
so the analysis is very simple when you
enter the procedure you're in a confined
region and then the unconfined regions
are exactly those areas of the code that
are dominated by a successful limit
check and so that you know this way we
we don't you put any prescriptions on
you know where the limit check has to be
or exactly you're what you're allowed to
with it so there's one restriction with
it you're not allowed to make a call in
the confined Regent because that can
consume unbounded stack space so i don't
think i'm going to talk about the the
recovery so where we are into the
problems that we we think we know how to
solve it's easy to do a limit check in
every procedure it's your easy to
implement your various popular policies
for for real holding the stack limit
what we don't know how to do is
something like what you'd find in the
capriccio thread system where they have
a whole program analysis that chooses
exactly where to put the limit checks
and and so that you amortize the cost of
a limit check over multiple calls and
you our model we don't know how to share
the right information that only the
backend has to make that kind of whole
program analysis possible in the front
end so are now sort of getting into
things that you know you were less and
less certain about what do we do when
the stack does overflow well we have a
way to identify the stack that that
failed and the sort of you know two
simple strategies are to move the whole
stack to someplace bigger or to just
perhaps move the failing frame or a
couple of frames and create a new a new
stack segment if we're going to segment
the stacks then we have to worry about
you know what happens when we cross that
segment boundary going the other way now
we've introduced stack underflow we have
to think about you know how much
hysteresis so that there you're there
aren't a lot of under flows and
overflows in inner loops so it's very
unclear how we're going to proceed with
this we're leaning a little bit on
some work that can't dip Vic did with
with the Shea scheme a couple of nice
pldi papers so trying to figure out how
do we adopt those techniques and use
them in the C minus minus setting so now
i get from things that we sort of have
some ideas here this is now the complete
pie-in-the-sky slide and so this is this
is what i'd like to do and i have no
idea how to do it this thinking about
you what kind of abstraction would we
like to present to clients to deal with
the stack well the call stack is linked
list is actually a pretty nice model you
can what think kinds of things can you
do with a linked list well you know you
can move a record anywhere you like and
update the links it's easy to insert
things into a linked list delete things
from a linked list you can you copy
things in a linked list you're going to
be a two different linked list that that
share tales how can we do this and still
have the sort of efficient to call and
return that were that we're used to most
of the time how can we do this and you
support locality so that you're you know
frames that are adjacent in the
abstraction are also adjacent in memory
so those are the problems the reason
that I'm excited about trying to do this
is that if we can manage this we can do
a lot more than just just threads so we
can have your stack 'let's which is a
very lightweight approach to segmented
stacks you think about incremental stack
scanning for improving pause times in
garbage collection you can imagine well
I've got a stack I'm going to scan the
three youngest frames and I'm going to
stop scanning there and insert something
that says well if I return here let me
scan another few frames and and so on
and so forth and of course if you have
this kind of stuff you can easily
implement first class scheme
continuations you can copy an entire
stack copy parts lazily so on and so
forth so you know this is you know I've
got a first year grad students signed up
to work on this I think this is you'll
be very exciting to take some of these
really gnarly implementation techniques
and find a nice way to package them up
and I hope
we can do it so you are thinking on
concurrences that you we acknowledge the
memory model and synchronization as
interesting and important problems but
we really feel like our challenges with
the stack particularly overflow and
underflow and at the far as a
compile-time interface i think that the
limit check is a necessary step and and
one that will will do a lot for us and
then there's this very fuzzy goal of
saying well can we make the stack look
like a linked list so that's everything
that I wanted to tell you about I want
to sort of leave you with the you want
to think of the the high points of the
the work that we're doing the C minus
minus is a kind of compiler
infrastructure with a little bit of a
different focus not just thinking about
optimization but really trying hard to
support multiple programming languages
as well as multiple machines when the
goal is multiple languages it's hard to
work with high-level abstractions
because when you pick a high level
abstraction it often comes with
semantics and cost trade-offs that are
not going to be right for every client
so we're trying to work around that by
having primarily low-level interfaces
mechanism that you're different front
ends can combine in different ways to
get the abstractions that they want and
really the key idea that makes it
possible for us to do this is a to
interface idea that both the compile
time and the runtime interface so we
spent quite a bit of time exploring this
strategy and for exceptions it works
pretty well I haven't talked about
garbage collection but it also works
very well in that setting it didn't
really work for procedures so we had to
resort to different techniques for
exposing the the procedure semantics and
the cost trade-offs in the
implementation and then as I said I
think the most important problem we have
left is what kind of infrastructure
should be provide for concurrent
languages
so I've had a lot of help with all this
many students and colleagues I was
thinking that lights almost half of the
people on this list are current or
former Microsoft employees and you are
very lucky to have them I've been been
privileged to work with them and you can
sort of go to our website and play with
the system I'd be delighted to get your
feedback so could you talk a bit about
the experience people are using this for
language engineers has very early
adopters so it's it's it's really been a
mixed in a mixed bag we've the the
high-order bit of the experience is that
people seem quite keen to play with
their compilers and add a C minus minus
back end and it seems to be a pretty
easy thing to do and then they get to
the runtime system and they want no part
of it so that the you know the the hired
a bit is that we seem to understand
fairly well the kinds of assumptions
compiler writers have made and have
produced an interface that's congenial
to them but the runtime the runtime
stuff is another story so that's been
the story with Milton that's been the
story with GHC John R epi keeps talking
about using a mobi but he also keeps
wanting the the OS 10 back end which is
not yet emerged from the graduate
students office Craig Chambers has
probably pushed things the farthest and
he's got a c-minus minus back end for
Roland and I don't know he he was
playing around with this stuff maybe
eight months ago and he's had some
undergrads doing some things so that's I
yeah that's so the the you the one thing
we will learns at you if you already
have a big run time system it's going to
be a lot harder than we thought to port
it to c minus minus that's sort of
scratching our heads and figuring out
what to what the other thing that we've
learned is that you your people already
have compilers they really want you to
give them a lot before they'll try your
stuff so usually should we've had we
also some odd things that I from people
I don't know and so it's hard to
evaluate their doing so there's a guy at
Johns Hopkins who's starting a you C
minus minus as a back-end for a new
language he's doing from scratch that i
don't understand and have just had this
barrage of questions about various
design decisions there are some people
in Kansas who are trying to use C minus
minus as a front end for a hardware
synthesis language again I don't quite
understand what yeah this is not what we
intended so I don't I don't understand
what leverage their they're seeing their
series so you mentioned what obstacle
which is just there's a large problem
for you to see my slightly is there
something I mean that's sort of a
sociological thing which is
anyways got a large artifact is going to
be reluctant to modify it unless there's
some substantial one um do you think
that there I mean art are we still sort
of struggling with writing extractions
or is the invitation efficiency of you
can apply these abstractions but they're
not as efficient as you know no I think
we're still struggling with the right
abstrait so the other the you're the
people in our community who who you want
to do things that really scale on the
kitten so there's her probably heard
from four or five people that says I'm
eager to try it once you solve the
threads problem and that that's a case
where we really don't know what the
right abstractions are there you there
some other thing we've we've learned in
the north so for example only in the C
minus minus interface says that the
front-end runtime system can ask about
any variable in the source code so we
did some experiments with Milton with
the Craig's front end I had a student do
these this summer it turns out that on
average at the average call site
ninety-seven percent of variables are
dead and this is because you people use
variables like temporary registers and
they know they're not going to ask about
them at runtime so there you there are
some things that we r you you would
probably will put into the interface the
idea of an unnumbered variable that you
can't ask about you there are some other
things where people think there are some
efficiency gains to be had and say well
I just care about these group of
variables and I don't want to refer to
them individually I just want to be able
to iterate over the group and the
obvious thing there is the roots for the
garbage collector and yeah there's some
nice you know your papers in the
literature this as well if you just know
these things are in a group I can make
sure that when they're spilled to the
stack there in adjacent locations or
other games you can play these are kind
of in the noise I think in terms of
giving you your little performance you
thinks the wheel
you the real open question is how does
this correspond to the existing
structure the compiler and just they've
been there been a couple of classes and
students who've just built toy compilers
from scratch on top of this and they're
very happy but that wasn't the only
audience we were aiming for son and I
have worked on GHC went through one
convulsion about two or three years ago
and we're starting a second one you were
doing these big refactorings of the gh
sees back end to make it fit better with
C minus minus and Simon is ecstatically
happy because he sees big improvements
what he perceives to be big improvements
and it's the structure of his compiler
at each iteration but I'm a little
discouraged because I see how far we
have to go and when I look at the
structure there they've got a runtime
system that's almost forty thousand
lines of C code and when I look at the
structure that trying to figure out how
to make that play nicely with these
abstractions where those abstractions
were not designed into the runtime
system yes I don't you know I don't know
if this is that we're going to be useful
for legacy systems just don't know it's
possible but it's definitely going to
give the yeah it's definitely be more
work than I expected for these discounts
practical systems yeah I think they're
really interesting questions in runtime
systems and if you think about that you
have that picture they had your security
model threads garbage collector type
system all these things that are above
the level of semis minus well you really
like to get some reuse in that domain as
well I think there are a lot of
interesting interesting things to think
about their imagine you have these two
interfaces as the code and the interface
the whole thing is certain that would be
for ye program part the left side right
that's right that's it sassy API it's a
it's a capi so our hope is that if you
run tight your runtime system might well
be written in C or something that can
call but yeah it's it is a risk so I was
you're talking with with the young vtec
who used the mmt k this sort of nice
garbage collection tool kit the steep
Blackburn and others worked on it's
written in Java and I'd love to hook
that up to c minus minus but it's just
not clear to me that it's going to be
it's going to be possible so I yeah I
don't you know I don't know how that's
going to
if I mean if we were living in the
windows world it make it a calm objects
and that would that would be a better
story but we didn't we didn't want to
live just in the windows world
government is going to be here some
people understand know if you're
interested talking please let me